WE NEED TO FIND OUT
WHETHER A MAGAZINE
WOULD ACTUALLY SET ON FIRE
WHEN IT'S PUT IN A TOASTER.
OKAY.
Narrator:
THERE ARE THREE INGREDIENTS
TO THIS BOURNE-STYLE GETAWAY --
THE TOASTER, THE MAGAZINE,
AND THE NATURAL GAS.
AND FIRST IN THE MIX
ARE ONE AND TWO.
HOW LONG DOES IT TAKE
TO TOAST A MAGAZINE?
YOU READY?
I'M READY.
ALL RIGHT.
THE GUYS START THE CLOCK
USING A MAGAZINE
LIKE THE ONE IN THE MOVIE
AND A TOASTER
RIGGED TO STAY ON.
YOU KNOW, IN THE MOVIE,
IT WAS ALREADY ON FIRE
AT THIS POINT.
AS IT TURNS OUT,
TOASTING A MAGAZINE
TAKES A LITTLE LONGER
THAN THE 20 SECONDS OF THE FILM.
OH, THREE MINUTES
OVER SCHEDULE.
I THINK
WE'RE REALLY CLOSE.
IN FACT,
IT TAKES OVER 12 MINUTES
BEFORE THEY GET IGNITION.
HEY, WE GOT FIRE!
TA-DA!
[ LAUGHS ]
[ Laughing ] REMEMBER, KIDS,
WE'RE PROFESSIONALS.
[ LAUGHS ]
SO, REALITY IS 12 MINUTES,
VERSUS THE MOVIE'S
25-SOME-ODD SECONDS.
HEY!
WE GOT FIRE!
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WELL, WHAT I THINK
IS THAT THIS MAGAZINE
IS A WORST-CASE SCENARIO,
BECAUSE LOOK HOW THICK
THOSE PAGES ARE.
AND MAGAZINES ARE
ALL DIFFERENT SHAPES AND SIZES.
SO YOU THINK WE SHOULD TRY
A WHOLE BUNCH
OF DIFFERENT KINDS
OF MAGAZINES
AND SEE IF THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT RATES
AT WHICH THEY CATCH ON FIRE?
EXACTLY.
I LOVE IT.
LET'S DO IT.
LOTS OF TOASTERS NOW.
Narrator: IT'S CLEAR
THE REAL-WORLD MAGAZINE
DOESN'T LIGHT UP
LIKE ITS MOVIE COUNTERPART,
SO NOW THE MYTHBUSTERS
ARE ON THE TRAIL
OF A BEST-CASE SCENARIO.
Adam:
IN ORDER TO COVER OUR BASES HERE
AND WORKING OFF THE THEORY THAT
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MAGAZINES
COMPOSED OF DIFFERENT KINDS
OF PAPER
ARE GOING TO CATCH A LIGHT
AT DIFFERENT RATES,
WE'RE ABOUT TO PUT A HALF-DOZEN
OF THEM TO THE TEST --
EVERYTHING
FROM OUR ORIGINAL MAGAZINE
TO SOMETHING MUCH HARDER
TO CATCH ON FIRE,
COMIC BOOK, SOMETHING
THAT WILL PROBABLY CATCH ON FIRE
IN, LIKE, SECONDS.
WE'RE GONNA PUT ONE
IN EACH OF THESE TOASTERS,
START THIS TIMER,
AND LOG HOW LONG EACH OF THEM
TAKES TO CATCH A LIGHT.
WHAT COULD BE MORE FUN?
Narrator: WELL, WITH
THE SIX MAGAZINES IN PLACE,
LET THE CHARGRILLING CHALLENGE
COMMENCE.
[ CHUCKLES ]
WE'RE EXPERIMENTALLY
DOING SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD JUST NEVER,
EVER BE DONE.
I LIKE THAT.
OH.
OH!
FLAME.
NUMBER 3.
1:40.
THIS TIME AROUND,
IT SEEMS THE CONTENDERS
ARE A LITTLE QUICKER TO TOAST.
2:20.
YEP.
HERE WE GO.
NUMBER 4.
3:15.
WHOA!
NUMBER 1.
3:20.
[ LAUGHS ]
LET'S LISTEN
FOR THAT SOUND.
[ FLAME POUFS ]
THERE WE GO.
THERE IT IS.
4:36.
AND, FINALLY,
BRINGING UP THE REAR...
THERE IT IS.
...IS THE ORIGINAL MAGAZINE
AT 12 MINUTES.
Jamie: AS WE SUSPECTED,
IT DOES MAKE A DIFFERENCE
WHAT KIND OF MAGAZINE
IS STUCK IN YOUR TOASTER.
THE BEST-CASE SCENARIO
IS SOMETHING THAT AMOUNTS
TO COMMON NEWSPRINT,
BUT EVEN THAT
TOOK ABOUT THREE TIMES AS LONG
AS WHAT IT DID IN THE MOVIE.
INTERESTING.
Narrator: SO, IT'S CLEAR
THAT EVEN WITH
THE BEST-CASE-SCENARIO MAGAZINE,
TOASTER IGNITION
TAKES A LOT LONGER
THAN THE 20 SECONDS
IT TOOK BOURNE.